his demeanor reminded me of the moment i
don't know if you remember this chris
there was a 60 minutes profile of aaron
rodgers and that's how we learned that
he's so sensitive he's sensitive about
being called sensitive some guy walked
up to him at some event and stood next
to him and said oh you're shorter than i
thought you would be and he said i don't
like that very much
that's that was that demeanor it
reminded me that same demeanor from
aaron rodgers last night so he begins
his stint as the guest host of jeopardy
and he continues to promote and he does
relentlessly relentlessly and
aggressively a level of promotion we
have never seen from him in his nfl
career because what he's trying to do
chris look i got this figured out and i
know aaron rodgers we are more alike
than he would ever admit and i'm sure
that he doesn't want to admit he has
anything don't admit it he's
trying to shut up he's trying to goose
the ratings he's doing everything he can
to put the thumb on the scale so he is
going to blow dr mehmet oz okay who had
the two weeks ahead of time and he wants
his job it's clear he wants this job he
is violating the first rule of
professional aspiration it specifically
is something that i learned in the
political field not that i was ever
involved in it and never will be but you
never talk about the jobs that you want
and he's talking too much about the job
that he wants if he doesn't get it he's
going to be regarded as a failure well i
mean maybe i i give him a lot of credit
this is why i like aaron rodgers he puts
himself out there all the time i think i
i'm like shocked with how aggressive he
is with pubbing this thing and
everything like that you know i i
thought it was an enjoyable show it's
the first time the guy's ever hosted
something in his life i thought it was
pretty damn good but i'm with you i am
like surprised at how aggressive he's
promoting it and loving it and just
everything about it uh either way it was
a good watch and you know i'm a jeopardy
watcher so i've been watching these
guest hosts over the last you know two
months or so and i would say it's as
good as good as anybody that's been up
there so far so be interesting to see
where it goes certainly
i haven't watched much of the others
yeah but i did watch last night's show
and here's my
non-qualified tv critic assessment i
think that and he's got nine more shows
and we talked about this yesterday
his comments about everything he studied
and every correct answer that every word
every phrase everything that that alex
rebecc did he was trying to don't be
alex trebek aaron and it's too late it's
already done yeah but we'll see what
happens over the next nine he's got to
be himself as the host of jeopardy it
was too obvious he was trying to be alex
trebek and there were moments where he
was lacking energy you know one of the
things i remember about alex trebek when
it's rolling and they're getting him
right he's got a punch he's got a little
and it's not like he says much but
there's an energy there's a punch there
and i felt like aaron didn't have that
because he was trying too hard to to be
impersonating
what he thought alex trebek would be
doing instead of just being himself
that's my that's my unqualified tv
critique of aaron rodgers performance i
hear you i mean they've all tried to
stay a little
you know in the lines of alex trebek he
probably did it more than anybody so far
to this point um but we'll see let's see
what's like what show two looks like
maybe he gets more relaxed after one
show and things like that and starts to
add his own you know personality to it
to everything in that way you know again
hey listen you know yeah he made a few
good jokes and cracks yeah that was
funny mike here's another thing i get
done watching the show last night big
phil calls right you know and listen me
and my dad this is what we do we talk
about football he brought up something
really interesting that i'm mad that i
hadn't thought about you know we talked
about like you know why didn't the
packers convert his money into a bonus
right but yeah it would have added more
to the you know end of the end of the
contract later years things like that
and we kind of talked about it the whole
time like you know the packers didn't
want to do that what if it's the
opposite what if it was aaron rodgers
that said no
and the more i thought about it i think
yeah go ahead
i think they have if somebody reported
that they had the power to do it a lot
of teams negotiate into the contract the
power to do a restructuring
automatically anytime they want to i
know the cowboys have that with dak
prescott and i think the packers have it
with aaron rodgers i know so they could
have done it even if he said no well i i
i texted with some people to try to
figure out a few things about that last
night and just to hear it but it it's
something that jumped out maybe we could
both look into it a little bit more but
uh either way it's shocking that he's
this aggressive with jeopardy right and
i think it's i mean it's really funny
that he's saying he could do both i mean
the way he broke it down it was like
they only tape for 47 days a year and we
play football for 187 there's all these
days left over
it's the brandon marshall when he was
flying to new york on days off right to
do
inside the nfl yeah the problem is this
here's the problem
during football season
is it responsible no for him
to fly to california to do
a day of taping and then come back is
that responsible no it's not it's it's
too hard to play quarterback and if you
have a bad game or throw interceptions
you know that's going to be the first
thing that everyone says well if you
weren't hosting jeopardy and being mr
alex trebek you might have played better
on sunday so that's what you're going to
be risking if you try to play that game
well and he clearly wants to do it he
wants the job he's not afraid to say he
wants the job
i just think that that if he gets the
job and who knows maybe he's at the
point where with his career in the
packers where he's willing to do it just
as a way to stick it to them maybe
that's his ultimate way to stick it to
them hey guys you're not making a
commitment to me i'm not making a seven
day a week commitment to you tuesday's
my off day it's my off day for a reason
i'm taking off to california i'll see
you
on wednesday and we'll worry about
getting ready for the game you're not
going out of your way to help me i'm not
going out of my way to help you now i
don't know they would ever put it that
way but that's the message that would
come from it if he would do it so we'll
see what happens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports